it's great to have you here at fight
fest you're here with your film the
inside tell me about your role in it I
play a character called Sienna who is a
the leader of the pack within the five
girls in the film
she's a very ballsy character yeah she's
the one that gets into trouble a lot and
causes all the mischief so she's she's a
fun one to play you know is that a
characteristic that came naturally to
you to play unfortunately yes
no I am quite opposite to her I love I
would like to be that ballsy and to have
the courage she has you know yes I think
that's what attracted me to her when you
kind of put that role away as an actress
and you move on to next projects you
kind of take any of it with you because
you say you'd like to maybe be a little
bit more like that if I think in certain
situations you kind of think back and
cut and say like God Sienna would do
this I wouldn't do this what Sienna do
this and sometimes I'm like you know
maybe I pretend to be Sienna tonight I
don't know how healthy that is but yeah
that can happen I like it I like it so
and tell me a little bit more about the
movie cuz it as you say it's very
intense isn't it how'd you get prepared
for those kind of roles for that I
literally I'm not normally a method
actor do Meisner
but for this I felt was very important
to stay in that character and all the
other actors they're so intense and so I
just I stayed at Siena the whole time of
your shooting and in terms of
preparation I let it be completely
organic because I didn't know the venue
is shooting in I didn't know we had the
script but then I didn't know her scenes
were gonna play out because everything
constantly kept changing even the the
monster scene I didn't see him until we
actually shot so when I seen him I was
like yeah this is gonna be kind of
difficult I'm gonna have some stupid
wants to compare me like ah but it was
so terrifying to me to see this
grotesque thing you know so yeah it was
all it was actually all quite natural
that doesn't usually happen for me
anyway I'm usually like super super
prepared but for this I'm like
all new to me so I'm just gonna go with
it you know when you're staying in Rouen
like that like you do for this film how
does that work when you kind of thing
family and friends outside well a lot of
other actors don't like you sometimes
because you you know especially to my
character so [ __ ] I think a lot of
people on set thought I was that girl
so after afterwards I'm like hey
actually I'm not her with my family and
friends I tried not to see anybody
because I didn't want them to have to
tell her that you know yes and I just
tried not to see anybody and while I was
shooting he mentioned the monster in the
film which is super scary isn't it
what kind of stuff scares you in real
life they when you're not on set being
surprised by monsters and what scares me
it's definitely supernatural to violence
and things like it's none of that scares
me I go watch fights and very nice yeah
like all that but in real life
supernatural stuff anything yeah and
anything demonic really would terrify me
no to do even if there was a room they
had painters and all demonic symbols
that terrifies the hell out of me you
know and so if you were in a house by
yourself in the middle of nowhere and
you heard a noise in the basement or the
Attic what would be your reaction I
would probably go check to see whatever
it is you know you know when you're
sitting in the cinema and you're like
why would you go in there I would be the
girl I would be the idiot that would be
like I just want to check it out you
know the fatal mistake is it a fatal
mistake but you know curiosity killed
the cat and finally what's next for you
now Kelly so next week I'm in Galway I'm
shooting a film called the O'Brien's
I play a character called Sasha it's a
complete opposite of Siena so a little
romantic comedy so a nice little change
you know rolling hills of Galway not in
a dirty old warehouse getting killed
there were lots of low without show you
have loads of fun and lots of luck with
the inside tears let me to speak to you
you